direkt an der nordsee im
niedersächsischen ort da ich steht seit
einem jahr diese vogelbeobachtung hütte
gekostet hat der bau rund 50.000 euro
aber die schicke hütte hat einen
gewaltigen nachteil es darf keiner rein
sie ist geschlossen
der grund für die treppe zur hütte gibt
es keine baugenehmigung der städtische
schwarzbau darf nicht betreten werden so
etwas hinzustellen für so viel geld und
dass man dann nicht die treppe benutzen
kann das halte ich auch ein bisschen für
ja wahnsinn das ist dummheit einfach du
mal das zu übersehen
wir leben in deutschland und dafür
vermutlich brauchen für alles eine
genehmigung es ist ein witz für mich ich
kann nicht etwas bauen wollen keinen
zugang zu habe die kommune plant die
neuen beobachtungsposten penibel vier
jahre lang im september 2017 wird die
hütte schließlich auf den damm gesetzt
direkt ans weltnaturerbe wattenmeer
das problem während der jahrelangen
planungen hat keiner daran gedacht für
die treppe ein bauantrag zu stellen aber
ohne treppe darf hier keiner rein
verbockt hat den treppen wird die
kurdirektion ort da ich der kurdirektor
teilt uns schriftlich mit man hoffe dass
der schwarzbau nachträglich genehmigt
werde
aber sie sollte für die treppe keine
baugenehmigung erteilt werden müssen wir
mit den zuständigen behörden über eine
andere lösung verhandeln
denn für die sicherheit des darmes ist
die untere deich behörde in aurich
zuständig und hier hält man die
metallkonstruktion für ein echtes risiko
ohne die im ergebnis vor zugreifen kann
man aber sicherlich sagen dass wir in
der sache erhebliche bedenken haben da
es sich um einen hochsensiblen bereich
handelt die bürgerinnen und bürger haben
für den bürokratischen irrsinn überhaupt
kein verständnis
der professionell finde ich es nicht
ich finde sie sollten darüber nachdenken
und das anständig machen ja
normalerweise gehört so was ordentlich
geplant also ich betrachte das als einen
witz eben als schildbürgerstreich und
vogelkundler halten die beobachtungs
hütte für komplett überflüssig
wir haben hier einen deich von dor von
man kann von jeder stelle aus die
vogelwelt wunderbar beobachten
dafür muss man sich nicht ein sohn
erhöhte verkriechen wann über das
schicksal des schwarzbaus entschieden
wird steht noch nicht fest wenn die
treppe tatsächlich weg muss wäre der
ganze bau ein 50.000 euro teures
missverständnis am wattenmeer